cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
what's up with that conversation about
it I'm not going to try to change your
mind but let's have a real conversation
and it's difficult to get that from the
left because they feel if they yell
louder at you that they're correct
that's the weird thing also it's a
charity golf tournament do you have to
even have the conversation just go be
polite to one another and move on with
your life yeah you know I asked look I
asked him I got a movie coming up in in
October and that I directed beautiful
movie It's called miracle in East Texas
please check it out it's
miracleanestaxes.com and it's a
wonderful movie it's a true story and I
asked them hey would you do an
endorsement for it and he goes well is
it like is it got like a Faith Message
to it I don't care but then why why ask
that yeah so like you brought up earlier
when people ask questions or they say
something they're the defense like well
um you know he's uh Epps isn't working
for us well we didn't we didn't say that
he was why are you defending yourself
with that so it makes you wonder about
what they're saying so I had a hard time
getting them to want to even give an
endorsement from my movie and we're in
the same industry and I said look I got
a wonderful cast of John ratzenberger
Lou gas at Jr Tyler Maine it's a
wonderful true story it's won 10 10 film
festivals so I was telling people right
now please go I got to get my plugin for
it can go to sorbelstudios.com actually
there it is we got we got it pulled up
tell us about what's going on it's a
true story set in 1930 and it's about
the largest oil found in the history of
the world true story it was about two
con Men played by myself and there's
John ratzenberger just the other side of
me there and next to Lou aluga said and
they would go through Oklahoma and Texas
wooing widows out of their money on fake
oil wells they would sell 500 of the
shares declare a dry hole going to the
next city they get down to Texas in the
Kilgore area they strike oil by accident
largest oil fine in the history of the
world I'm not giving anything away
because it's miracle in East Texas
there's other little miracles happen
along the way but it's it's one best
romantic comedy best faith film family
film uh the judge's favorite it's an
amazing movie we only got two days it's
a fathom movie and fathom gets
independent movies out there when 750
screens but we need people if you buy
tickets right now to sell this sucker
out we'll get more dates it's a PG film
you can take your six-year-old and I saw
that it's got the pay it forward method
too if you want to buy tickets it's a
wonderful true story and you'll laugh at
it it's just it's it's great and it's
really eventually it's how the hunt
family became so wealthy
well they became very wealthy the two
Hunt Brothers owned the Kansas City
Chiefs since the 1980s so wait wait
these guys were ripping people off and
accidentally were right they
accidentally struck oil and it was just
and my character wants to get attacked
out of Dodge John ratzenberger looks
just like the real guy in real life his
character
um he won dad Everett was was his name
he wanted to stay and said look we're
going to bring oil in US dude we sell
500 of the shares you can't have a 500
of the shares and we ripped off all
these other people now these other
cities he goes I'm an oil man I'm going
to do this in of course we get arrested
and it's during the court case and all
the widows come down to see us get get
hung basically
um and uh it's just a very fun movie dan
Gordon is the guy pictured just to my uh
to my right as I face it Dan Gordon
wrote this he's an Oscar nominated
writer he wrote hurricane for Denzel
Washington
wider up Kevin Costner wrote 60 episodes
of Highway to Heaven for Michael Landon
wow and that's my wife next to me she's
in the movie She produces a movie with
me and uh it's uh it's a wonderful
wonderful family movie so please for all
those fans that keep saying please make
more movies like this I don't have a
hundred million dollar advertising
budget like avatars do we need Word of
Mouth more than anything else so 39 days
still comes out yes what's the October
October 29th and 30th and if we sell out
these theaters they're gone it's going
pretty good right now if we sell them
out we'll get more days but this at
least gets us into the theaters and
that's what fathom is able to do for
independent movies what's fathom fathom
is a company that gets gets movies like
my independent movies in theaters
documentaries gives you two days you got
to get out there and really hit the hit
the pavement to do promotion work I've
already done probably 80 interviews in
the last three weeks with another
another 80s to do before the thing comes
out so that's why I'm on the road right
now doing it they do a great job to get
it out there but it's up to me to do the
promotional work and I appreciate you
guys giving me a plug for it because
this movie is great for the whole family
you will love it and it's a true story
which I absolutely love all the music is
1930 or earlier all the cars in 1930
earlier and one of the trains it's about
an hour and 45
one of the two working trains in all of
North America pre-1930. wow oh nice so
we got to use the train what's good
production about it what's it what is it
is it 30th a Saturday
uh no I think it's I think it's a it's a
Saturday Sunday isn't it oh okay even
better yeah let me uh let me double
check anything under two hours oh no no
no it's Sunday Monday it's Sunday my
Sunday my Sunday Monday so we get more
days obviously we'll get more more time
for it to get out there but it like I
said great movie John ratzburger is
awesome and it uh Luke I said Junior the
guy in the beard in the far left that's
Tyler Maine a lot of people that are no
WWF guys he was a very famous wrestler
back in the 80s and 90s and he was um he
was Sabretooth and the X-Men movies and
he's Jason
he was great in this and as I told you I
love doing true stories and this is just
another really wonderful story and a
wonderful Dan Gordon script do you like
acting or directing better
um I started directing back on Hercules
by season three when I walked into
Universal I said hey talk to Sam Ramey
was our exact producer I said Sam Ramey
was the executive producer who did the
evil dads and he did all the first two
Spider-Mans and I said I can I'm gonna
direct he goes okay and I went well okay
thank you I thought there'd be some kind
of fight that I was kind of ready to go
but I started directing back then I love
the direct
um I did another movie early this year
called Left Behind rise of the
Antichrist left band is based on the 80
million Left Behind books it's written
by Jerry Jenkins right now his son
Dallas Jenkins is doing the chosen which
went to the fathom out as well the
chosen the chosen's doing really well
massive yes massive and they raised all
their money from people they raised 30
40 million dollars from people so it's
outside the Hollywood system and um I I
still if you're going to give me a
choice I'd still love acting more but uh
I I've got four of the movies in
post-production right now so I've been
I've been staying busy doing my own
thing are you acted in or directed I
acted I directed one other one but I I
acted in the other ones and I got two
documentaries that I produced that are
coming out later this year as well we
were talking about last night about uh
The Disaster Artist movie with uh James
Franco and James directed it and acted
in it right and how do you overcome as a
director and an actor like uh the
difficulty of not seeing yourself acting
as you're directing like do you how did
you go back and watch the
um I I trust usually I have ads that I
love to use and my wife is very smart
producer as well I trust their opinions
when I finish the scene but I usually
know I can get I can find myself I go
I'm acting right now I'm not doing a
bigger job but um I like to work fast
I'm a Believer in the way Clint Eastwood
Works he shoots eight hour days and
makes oscar-winning pictures I don't go
beyond I think 12 hours top but you
start wearing these directions that do
in the 16-hour days you don't have to
there's a lot of wasted time on sets as
you know I mean there's just a lot it's
a lot of hurry up yeah there's but then
it's like I I I'm like another ad in the
set what are we waiting for what's going
on so I always want to work with people
that work quick I want to DP that noses
lighting the DP we had here was great we
shot this in Canada actually and I
showed this movie to a group of people
in in Texas and they go I know where
that was I said no you don't I was
literally just going to ask where and he
said yeah so what once again it's Show
Business not show show they got a bigger
tax credit they get a bit dollars more
stronger up there the 3 000 acre ranch
that we shot in okay if you're looking
East you're looking at the Rocky
Mountains in downtown Calgary you're
looking West it looks like it looks like
Texas and that same that same location
we shot at Revenant was shot there
Leonardo DiCaprio they shot Lonesome
Dove there okay they shot open range
with Kevin Costner and they shot Clint
East as Unforgiven it's good enough for
Clint Eastwood that location is good
enough for Kevin's Circle
you're a good man got 10 tickets for us
on the crew you are awesome our theaters
got it our theater down the street yeah
all you gotta do is plug in your zip
code and right now you can thank you for
that information yeah but all the
theaters you'll love this movie you'll
love this movie it's just it's just a
lot of fun and make sure you stick
around for the credits because the
outtakes are hilarious and there's one
less thing that happens in all the
credits roll that I added that I think
you'll get a big laugh out of it first
yeah the story sounds awesome it sounds
sounds like a fun movie it's fun right I
like the I I like the story idea a fan
of your work but uh on top of that
we're dealing with an industry that
kicked you out not for no reason other
than your private personal life and
beliefs even though even though you are
uh you have the biggest show uh I I
don't know
Hercules was the most watched show in
the world by season three we're in 176
countries Andromeda was 150 countries in
the in the number one shown first one
syndication in America so you are
a superstar you're making money for the
industry hands down and they say no you
not to believe these things so we're
getting rid of that we we should support
films like yours
so that we can tell that industry that
I'll refrain from swearing to please
please leave us alone please leave but
look at the movies they're putting out
there right now the Disney's looking at
a billion dollar loss this year more
than a billion dollars out of 20. I do
movies that are in the three million
dollar range I do movies that are fun
they're family these are movies
Hollywood used to do movies that had
hope and love and laughing we were
talking about this we talked about this
last night uh Groundhog Day Masterpiece
great movie but what was the budget on
that thing super low right I mean it's
just oh I can't imagine they put they
probably shot there for 15 million it's
it's a it's a it's it's just good actors
and Comedians In This Place yeah and
then in 20 out of the top 20 movies that
made me that made the top 20 in the box
office this year 10 of them financially
lost money
10 of them were box that were did not
make enough Indiana Jones is going to
lose about a terrible 800 million
dollars so I tried watching it it's just
I'm sorry well they make the woman the
big star again they took away Indiana
Jones from Indiana Jones and that's what
most of these movies are doing is this
emasculation of men it's just that women
are the big badasses the men are a bunch
of losers and the sad thing is is like
the the what you when you say 100
million dollar budget that's actually
the low end now like well that was about
a three that was a 280 million dollar
budget yeah the the ones without lost
money the ones that gambled on 200 to
250 million dollar budgets there was
others that were more than that uh
because coveted restrictions ended up
setting people back large for your time
so out of those top five movies four
were all 100 million dollar movies that
ended up making extreme amounts of money
because they did good marketing at the
bottom end of that list you have sound
of freedom and two horror movies all of
which spent less than 16 million dollars
to make 100 over 100 years about 14.5
million on a budget I saw the movie
three years ago Jim Caviezel and I had
the same manager for a year so I I saw
the movie a while ago they made it five
years ago and uh and that movie they had
a bite back from Disney because Disney
sat and did nothing with it so they
needed to make 50 million to break even
and they did and I had 175 million it
made more money than Indiana Jones
you know what field that number one
Angel Studios Angel Studios has been
chosen they go on they got they got I
don't know 100 million people that you
know watched them and they said support
this movie so they did Hollywood came in
and attacked the movie so basically
Hollywood said hey
we don't want we're not against child
sex trafficking we're for it we're
pedophiles and I think there's it made
people angry on the left side and the
right side there's plenty of people that
are atheists like people that are on the
left they don't want child sex
trafficking either so they went to the
movies if there were if there were some
some Communists who made a movie yeah
and they had conservative actors in that
film and they were trying to make the
story of a young communist on an
adventure and it was a very ideological
film but they were super chill and being
like hey man we don't we don't want to
judge you we just want to you know make
a film I'd have respect for that but
it's it's worse they're making over
budget bad movies regurgitated movies
while telling you that you are not
worthy to be in their presence so I say
screw them we support people who are
nice and who believe in good things and
so whether it's sound of Freedom or
Miracle in East Texas these are the kind
of movies I would much rather pay to see
and pay extra to see and pay it forward
for other people to see simply to tell
I'm gonna refrain from swearing these
jerks to to shove off if they were nice
I I'd say I'm sorry your movie didn't do
well but they are not nice people they
are mean and nasty people so they don't
deserve success thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time